maintenant qu'on sait que les vacciner
peuvent transmettre tout comme les non
vaccinés mois - certes mais ils peuvent
continuer de transmettre à quoi sert
encore se passe a dit hier ils étaient
là pour que les français se vaccine
maintenant il est là pour que les
vaccins pour que les français pardon
prennent la troisième dose est-ce qu'il
va rester pour les 4e 5e 6e dose est ce
qu'on va avoir maintenant impasse
élitaire avis la question il faut la
poser aujourd'hui parce que elle est
essentielle sur la suite de la société
qu'on va construire et je crois que moi
pourquoi je suis contre ce pas salutaire
parce que pour moi c'est quelque chose
qui va au delà de la stratégie sanitaire
et du vaccin c'est quelque chose qui va
au delà qui rentre finalement dans la
vie quotidienne et qui ne devrait jamais
rentré dans la vie quotidienne parce que
ça veut dire que là vous êtes en
fonction de certains choix personnel en
fonction de la façon dont vous êtes
construits ou vous obéissez ou pas au
gouvernement vous avez droit à des
choses ou non au gouvernement il
gouverne sans contre-pouvoir sous le
sceau du secret défense c'est
inacceptable et les français n'acceptent
malheureusement ça sur le mode de
gouvernement je suis d'accord avec vous
sur le fait que dire que ce sont des
choix personnel je suis moins avec vous
on a déjà eu ce débat pour moi hein
c'est pas un choix personnel de passeurs
vacciner quand vous pouvez le répandre
faire du mal à des plus faibles des plus
âgés et que c'est pas un choix
uniquement personnel que le gouvernement
doit légiférer
et commander selon le bien commun tels
qu'ils l'estiment aujourd'hui bien
commun commandes que les gens soient le
plus vaccinée possible parce qu'on voit
que ça fait diminuer la contamination la
transmission ça fait diminuer les formes
graphiques c'était diminuer le nombre de
morts et il était il était fondé à
inciter les gens à aller se faire
vacciner fille après on va se retrouver
à vendre ou une obligation vaccinale un
jour si les gens ne vont pas faire
d'excès